analicemos lo que sucede con la media y
la mediana de un conjunto de números
cuando cambiamos uno de los números
veamos este ejemplo a un grupo de cuatro
amigos les gusta jugar al boliche juntos
y cada uno de ellos lleva un registro de
su mejor puntaje en un solo juego todos
sus puntajes más altos se encuentran
entre 180 y 220 a excepción del de adán
cuyo puntaje más alto es de 250 adam
tiene un juego excepcional y su nuevo
puntaje más alto es de 290 como afectará
a la media y la mediana el incremento
del puntaje de adán como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolverlo por su cuenta vamos a
pensar acerca de lo que nos están
diciendo hay cuatro amigos y cada uno
lleva un registro de su mejor puntaje
así que vamos a tener cuatro datos que
serán el mejor puntaje de cada uno de
los amigos digamos que este es el
puntaje más bajo este es el segundo más
bajo este es el segundo mejor y ese es
el mejor puntaje sigamos analizando
todos los puntajes más altos se
encuentran entre 180 y 220
a excepción del de adán cuyo puntaje más
alto es de 250 así que antes de que adam
tenga este juego excepcional los
puntajes estarían así el menor es de 180
el mejor es el de adán que es de 250 y
si quitamos el puntaje de adán el
siguiente más alto es de 220 y no
conocemos este otro puntaje como se ve
el conjunto de datos después de que adam
tiene el juego excepcional con puntaje
de 290 bueno el puntaje más alto de este
amigo no cambia el puntaje de este otro
amigo tampoco cambia el puntaje del
tercer amigo tampoco cambia pero ahora
adam tiene un nuevo puntaje más alto que
es de 290 la primera pregunta que nos
hacemos es cambio la mediana recordemos
que la mediana es el número de en medio
por lo que al tener cuatro números aquí
la mediana la vamos a encontrar con el
promedio de los dos números de en medio
así que calculamos el promedio de este
número cualquiera que sea y de este 220
y nos va a dar la mediana en este otro
caso cuando adán tiene un nuevo puntaje
más alto como calculamos la mediana
seguimos teniendo cuatro números y los
dos números de enmedio siguen siendo los
mismos cualquiera que sea el puntaje más
alto de este amigo y el puntaje de 220
del otro amigo la mediana no cambia
sigue siendo el promedio de esta
incógnita y este 220 la mediana no
cambia lo escribimos ahora pensemos en
la media para calcular la media sumamos
todos estos números y dividimos el
resultado entre 4 hacemos lo mismo para
calcular la media de este otro conjunto
sumar todos los números y dividir el
resultado entre 4 cuál suma será la más
grande los tres primeros números no
cambian pero el segundo conjunto tiene
un número más grande 290 es mayor que
250 si sumamos estos cuatro números y
los dividimos entre 4 vamos a tener un
resultado mayor que el del resultado de
la suma de estos otros 4 números y su
división entre 4 porque la suma del
primero es más grande por lo que la
media va a incrementar la mediana no
cambia y la media incrementa la primera
opción dice que ambas se incrementan lo
cual no es cierto
la segunda opción dice que la mediana
y la media queda igual lo cual no es
cierto porque la mediana no cambia la
tercera opción dice que la media
incrementa y la mediana queda igual esto
es exactamente lo que encontramos si
queremos hacer esto un poco más tangible
podemos reemplazar la incógnita con
algún valor digamos que este valor es
200 si probamos con 200 veremos qué es
lo que pasa
la mediana estaría en medio de estos dos
números y recuerden que escogimos 200 de
manera arbitraria pero puede ser
cualquier número entre 180 y 220 podemos
ver que para este ejemplo es muy claro
que la mediana no cambia pero la media
se incrementa porque la suma es mayor la
suma incrementa a 40 puntos porque el
último número incremento 40 puntos nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo